This just in.
NTSB investigators
say four bolts
that hold the door
plug in place on the Boeing 737
max, nine were missing
at the time of last month's
blowout on Alaska Airlines Flight 1282.
The near disaster happened
midair during a flight from Oregon
to California, 177 people were on board.
FAA chief Mike
Whitaker has been testifying today
on Capitol
Hill about his oversight
of Boeing following the incident.
We have seen an aviation correspondent,
Pete Monteith, here with us.
All right.
Tell us more about his testimony
and this new report.
Obviously,
those four bolts were very important.
This is a bombshell
finding from the National Transportation
Safety Board,
who just released this 19 page
report, its preliminary report
about that blowout back on January 5th.
And it essentially says
the Bolts,
which was have been the focus
of this investigation from the start,
were not there.
This is the actual type of bolt.
This is an
and six bolt pretty common in aviation.
This is the bolt itself.
There's a castle nut here
and then a cotter pin
to keep this all together.
At one point,
there was some conjecture
that maybe the Cotter pin was missing
that would cause this castle
not to work itself free.
In actuality, the NTSB says
none of these bolts were in place
at the time of this blowout.
Last month,
the NTSB was able to determine this
because they were able
to recover the door
plug that fell off Alaska
Flight 1282
in the Portland
backyard of a physics teacher.
They brought it to their lab in D.C.
to do something
called destructive testing.
And they were able to tell
from the telltale signs
on the door itself
and also on the fittings.
There
you could see those
on the side of the door there
that these bolts were simply
not installed.
The running theory from the NTSB
now is that these bolts were taken out
at some point
when this plane was very new
at first flew at the end of October.
But the fuselage was delivered
by a subcontractor to Boeing on September
1st of 2023 at Boeing.
Technicians
there noticed some issues with rivets
next to the door,
and they were able
to remove parts of the door
and door plug.
And the NTSB was able to tell from photos
taken of the work
that took place on September 19th
that the bolts were not installed then.
This only adds further scrutiny
to Boeing,
which is really under
a lot of pressure right now
when it comes to its quality control.
And the big question here
is why they removed those bolts
and why they did not put them back in.
That is something that the NTSB
is still trying to determine.
They want to figure out
what the instructions were specifically
that were in the instruction manuals
there for Boeing workers
at its plant in Renton, Washington.
Right now,
we just heard from the FAA administrator.
There are about two dozen
FAA inspectors there
conducting an audit of Boeing's
quality control.
But this is only the beginning.
This is just the preliminary report.
We will see a final report
probably in a year's time.
No laying
blame here by the NTSB on Boeing,
although we could find that in
a final report.
So just very quickly,
basically,
when this plane was pretty new,
yes, the door plug had to come off.
Yes. A reason, a rivet reason.
And when it was put back on the bolts
and the issue is the door plug itself,
which you can't see
from the inside of the airplane,
you can only see it from
the outside of the airplane,
goes through so many cycles
that the inside of the airplane expands
because of pressurization
and then contracts
when it's not pressurized.
So it's to hold it there in place.
But at a certain point,
essentially, this door just blew free.
And the NTSB says
the door blew out and up
and free of the airplane
in a very explosive and dramatic way.
We have seen the videos from on board.
It is pretty incredible
that everybody survived this
and nobody was seriously hurt.
Pete, thank you so much for that.
I do want to bring in CNN safety
analyst and former FAA
safety inspector David Susi.
Now, that is a bombshell, as Pete
said there,
especially Lee,
since it seemed before
this door plug blew off.
It was an airplane
that was kind of giving
some signs, right,
with the pressurization
issues that it had been experiencing
on multiple occasions.
You know,
three times before this,
they had pressurization indications
and the airplane was put on the ground.
They inspected it, they checked it.
They didn't go to the extent
of doing a pressurization
check on the ground,
which typically isn't done.
They'll do a couple of other things
before they do that.
But that's the one thing that I think
is missing here,
that this problem started long,
long before this actual door came out,
that's for sure, at Boeing.
What does this tell you, David,
about what happened here and how?
I mean,
do you understand
how this could have happened
that this door plug was put back on
without the bolts being there?
Yeah, absolutely.
I've been an aircraft mechanic,
licensed mechanic for 45 years.
I've worked on the line
installing aircraft
on the manufacturing line
and there's often a problem
between the communication,
especially in shift changes
where they change from one to the other.
But here's
the situation is manufacturing employs
a certain mindset
when that might a manufacturing process,
the assembly line process is interrupted
with the nonconforming part,
which as Pete mentioned,
there were rivets
that weren't installed properly
that had to be repaired.
At that point,
they're supposed to change their mindset
from being an assembly line
to being a repair station.
They're actually performing repairs,
which require additional inspections
when there's a safety of flight item.
They have to have someone
who did not work on that airplane
come in and do an inspection
to make sure it's ready to go.
So my question is not only why weren't
the bolts put in,
but why did that process
not happen at Boeing?
And that's what
the FAA needs to make their focus on
is what's going on
at Boeing in that culture
that would have allowed that to happen.
Yeah, huge questions
about Boeing's
culture that have persisted for years
and are ballooning again now.
David, great to have you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for having.